one of the biggest ones was game three
in 2001 when President Bush came out
throughout the first pitch through a
perfect strike and uh he actually came
in with his bulletproof vest in New York
we're playing the um the Arizona
Diamondbacks and we're down two nothing
and Mr Steinbrenner had brought back all
the all the police officers and
firefighters and people that lost their
loved ones I I it was it was probably
one of the the most emotional games I
had to pitch because when I busted out
of the locker room in old Yankee Stadium
I turn right and go about 20 yards to go
to the weight room to do my cuff work
and get loose I don't like running in
front of the fans and stuff I'll get on
a treadmill and get all my priests I
want to go out there I'm hot and here we
go
and I busted out of the clubhouse door
and like I had some men and women some
firemen just hugging me and yeah this is
a month after 9 11 not a year right so I
was supposed to pitch that so and I'll
tell you guys this one on the topic and
I'm thinking about it
I played 24 years I tell people I
consider myself a great team player
um
it pales to the trip that I did so I was
supposed to pitch 9 9 11. I was a New
York Yankee going against my former team
the Red Sox so everybody and their
mother were in town I was going for my
20th win
I usually try and sleep to about 8 30 on
on game day we get we get in about one
after night game order from the the
Yankee Stadium
my buddy was only two floors we got an
overlooked floor that upstairs I put
Turf in that you can kind of look out
the city real pretty eight miles nine
miles from the World Trade
banging my door down about eight eight
oh five
and I'm like man what's up something
happened to World Trade so out our bay
window up there on the 25th floor I
always see
um four-seat airplanes going down the
Hudson so I thought it was a mishap with
one of the planes that go down tour the
Statue of Liberty he goes no it's bigger
than that so we run up
we could hear and fill the second plane
go back down turn turn on the tube see
all hell's breaking loose Dorman's at my
places you guys need to they're going to
shut down Bridges you need to get out
and get out of here
so we went to my buddy's place we loaded
everybody up my wife was there had a
bunch of girlfriends there we had other
friends we called people were all in
town to watch my 20th
and we and we busted out of there fast
forward we all know what happened how
what happened in our lives and um our
world changed General Myers our
four-star general at the time went to
high school with my agents he he called
and said would rock it go to the Middle
East to see our men and women I said
call Drew Carey the comedian Drew went
with us uh told some jokes seven days a
booklet about the size of my iPhone
cover uh
uh military time
um
we lost one person when we were over
there it's really the only time I saw
jeremeyers get up and get upset and they
dressed him down until the media knew
that we're we went into Afghanistan to a
base they just bombed uh
but anyway uh I met uh you know again so
if anybody I had five uncles that served
I lost my oldest brother he served in
Vietnam
and so anytime just like I I let off
with this speech in front of the guys
because the Phillies actually have one
or two guys that had uh served and now
they're trying to pick up their baseball
career I mean back in the day Ted
Williams and all these guys
um is a normal thing back then but yeah
World War II yeah yeah uh uh um and uh
so anyway it was it was an unbelievable
trip
I saw uh you know people that again make
me feel comfortable on Center Stage in
front of 55 000 people to be able to do
my job uh that night that President Bush
threw out that first pitch there was I
was in the bullpen with smell stodemar a
pigeon coach we turned around with the
Silhouettes you could see about 14 15 uh
uh Sharpshooters on top of the stadium
and it was just and it lit up like a
Christmas tree he threw a beautiful
strike
the two stories you guys probably you
may have heard them already I'll tell
you the the two funny things I'll I'll
regress here in a minute but
um
uh I I knew we were really close with
41. I knew 43 but not as well as I did
we even called him Gambia that's why he
called a grandkids campy anytime I went
to Kenny bunkport we got to throw
horseshoes I got a damn horseshoe pit in
my house because of him he sent over 30
page fax on how to mix the clay with the
sand I mean he's serious about his HW
yeah he's serious
uh so
um uh 43
he's got the bulletproof vest under his
deal he wants to throw I said Mr
President you're going to have to
um
you're gonna have to go out the door go
to the right about 100 yards it's you
know the old Yankee Stadium you know
it's we got ghosts running around in
that place right and the the the the the
batting cages all the way down there I
said Posada and Jeter and come to guys
probably are doing their tea work or
whatever they're doing to get ready so
you'll see them he says great so he goes
down there
and uh those five or ten warm-up pitches
realize he can do it and then I wasn't
there this and this is the word I got
and I think it was on a documentary but
uh
he on his way out the door with all the
Secret Service he stops he sees Derek
shakes his hand he says Derek he goes uh
any pointers and Derek goes well Mr
President yeah you can't throw from the
grass not the dirt you got to get up you
know where rock is at on the Rubber and
you gotta let it fly from there oh hell
I can handle that no problem I can do
that and he says anything else he goes
yeah he goes this is New York Mr
President and if you bounce it they will
boo you
so he goes oh now I'm nervous yeah so so
he told that one my I'll go back to my
trip to the Middle East this is what
they all now
again I'm 6'4 they had two marines as my
bodyguards and they were both six sick I
look like a no no offensive punters and
then but I look like a punter standing
next to these guys and uh uh so they had
me covered they said when we could tell
you when you jump in the crowd and
you're signing for all our military guys
I'm gonna whisper in here you got two
minutes to get to the chase vehicle you
got to get the chase vehicle
no problem
and they they both so when I got to uh
we actually flew over on Air Force two
then when we got to Shannon Ireland we
jumped on they put me on a C-17
transport plane with 25 of the baddest
ass Marines you've ever seen in your
life
and these guys were getting on me
because I had a second suitcase I was
like one you know a chick you know I
brought you know the clothes and I had a
second flight buddy Pack Light no
they're on me so I told them I'm pretty
finicky about what I eat plus I got to
be careful with seafood iodine in it man
I look like Rocky Balboa within a you
know cut me Mick and uh so
um uh but in the second suitcase I had
nothing but oatmeal Cliff bar I had I
had a powder and and granola and
everything because uh the two times I
pitched for Team USA jumping here
getting long-winded on y'all but uh
playing for Team USA you know I I I I
went over there and a couple guys got
food poison we had to send them back and
I found like a chef Boyard for two weeks
I found like a chef boy or the uh uh uh
spaghetti and a Diet Coke and I lived
off that for seven days eight days over
there during during that USA game
so I was being careful I'm not going to
go over and get sick and uh so I got
this all this stuff never bitching a
moan at me about it but I was teasing my
agent before I went I said hey I'm
taking this extra suitcase full of stuff
because I'm not going to get over there
and you know eat a camel or something
funny isn't it funny so day six we're at
this princess thing in Kuwait City
they cook two Lambs in the ground they
bring them out now I sat at a table with
some of the guys I've gotten to know I
didn't want to sit at the head table
with all their you know all their people
and and uh everything that was going on
but General Myers is up there and
everybody else and they go you're up
here you're sitting front center with us
Roger Clemens head of the table so I'm
looking they gotta interpreter and
everything and they set the first way
and there's pot there's a pita bread
white rice and I got a diet seven up and
I'm saying okay I'm gonna this is this
go this is it's gonna be my meal
out of nowhere don't you know they drop
a baby camel right baby camel huh teeth
everything right here
and I'm like you guys are messing now
I'm getting punked yeah I said no you
guys messing with me now
and I said I'm not getting that well my
agent had the guy they cut into it and
we're not eating the first cut into it
by the by the hump
okay it looked like Bernays was coming
out of it all right I'm like you got to
be kid and they dug around with these
big tongs and then next thing you know
he pulled out some meat that looked like
shredded pork and he puts a softball
size on my plate and everybody's looking
at me and and these guys are like
they're all and Drew Carey's look and
I'm like and I pushed that around my
plate for like an hour an hour I didn't
care if we started a world war or
something you know you know so and then
and then uh uh uh Drew's girlfriend at
the time she she was dipping into my
stuff and I was like yeah y'all are
bitching you know getting on my ass for
bringing this and now now you want my
opinion yeah you want my oatmeal so
anyway but anyway if anybody out there
and you guys know uh if you if you
served or anybody has served I freaking
tip my hat to you and say thank you uh
it doesn't go unnoticed uh we do a
helping a hero dealer
um we got uh we're building 100 homes
for our military men and women that
serve for us and and gave the ultimate
sacrifice and uh we got Johnny Morris
from Bass Pro he's he's playing a big
role in this four so again I thank you
guys so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]